a venomous Cobra leaves its lair drawn
to the scent of hatching crocodile lays
when it comes upon the nest the Cobra
discovers another predator is already on
the scene a monitor lizard the lizard
isn't going to give an inch without a
fight
hey finders keepers buddy even if you
are venomous the lizard and the Cobra
size each other up then they try to
intimidate each other by increasing
their size if big is bad
each wants to say I'm the biggest and
the baddest the Cobra is poised to
strike and with that the monitor
retreats but not before taking a parting
shot
aha
no the cobra has the egg dinner all to
itself only the shells are empty the
monitor lizard has the last laugh the
battle was over even before it began